hi i'm maria and i'm alex today we will
be challenged to take a popular food and
make it fancy this episode is my first
time to tagging along with a friend and
i chose my bff hashtag relics let's see
what we are making fancy today drum roll
please we don't have a
pizza roll wow pizza rolls really do you
like pizza rolls i think i've never had
it before
try
[Music]
when i was a kid i used to eat these
like
they were you know
what do you eat a lot i like water
popcorn
it's basically a deconstructed pizza you
have that like dough on the outside
enveloping a nice pizza sauce some
cheese maybe on the pizza sauce it's
very saucy it's a little bit under
seasoned yeah this is a kid's food it
doesn't have to be
so many fond memories of united states
this pizza roll need a little bit of tlc
and we are excited to
make it fancy
all right here's what we got basil
parsley egg spirada black truffle butter
dopio zero flour extra fine like me
block truffle
pancetta butter heavy whipping cream
salad semolina flour why do you say
that's like sexy chop the calabrian
pepper garlic tomato paste and parmesan
and from the pantry we got garlic powder
salt black pepper extra virgin olive oil
and vodka
bye let's get started
make it fuzzy
[Music]
by the way riya i wore my fanciest
velvet pantsuit for you that's nice
so first bake this we are not cooking
hallway through we are just throwing in
the oven at 400 and for 10 to 12 minutes
easy enough
all right next step
i found some pearls on your set dissect
pizza roll and i'm gonna scrape out the
filling into a bowl here did you ever
dissect things in school yes we did fish
fish have you yeah i dissected
what
you are science major yeah i was we've
made it to the last two and we're gonna
save this for later bake these pizza
roll shells at 400 for 15 minutes and
make it very very crispy all right we
have our crispy
not gonna lie these look kind of good
yeah should i
try is it good
put this in
for the processor there we go
guess what song
pulsing seems to work better
so terminator yeah you're good let's put
in a mesh seam and make a fine powder
and sift this sifting we've got our big
chunks on top and a finer powder below
we're gonna need this fine powder just
two old things setting the breadcrumbs
aside and now we're ready to move on i
have seven on semolina flour seven ounce
wo flour two ounces of our extra fine
pizza roll flour two teaspoon of salt
mix it
make the magic happen
my mom once broke her hand in one of
these she stuck it in
and it twisted
she did it on christmas eve baking a
christmas cake she passed out on the
floor we had to call the ambulance and
we were all in the emergency room in
christmas onesies so i'm gonna put one
tablespoon of water in four eggs give
that a little whisk pour it in our flour
mixture
okay
take this out and start kneading
really someone who loves to do a lot of
things by hand if you don't know well
you can basically do almost everything
by hand we didn't have anything when we
were cavemen
that's true channeling our ancestor yeah
dough came together it's nice and bouncy
wrap this in a plastic rest this for
30 minutes
so we've rested the dough and we have a
baking sheet lined with some semolina
flour and we have a pasta attachment cut
this in a golf ball sides pop in here
[Applause]
teamwork makes possible work so we are
making a penne but um it's a little bit
bigger so it's almost look like a
rigatoni no it's a regular tortino we
are going to make pasta is all the dough
we have and then we're going to move on
to the next step 2 tablespoon of butter
my favorite food
butter now we're adding the bigger
chunks of our pizza roll shells season
this with a little salt
some pepper
oh for good luck
a little bit of garlic powder we're also
adding in some fresh parsley this is
looking good i think we're ready to move
on to the next step yeah wow look at our
pasta our rigatotino so cute look at
this it's very cute definitely this one
is a little bent out of shape i like
cauli one i like this one wow look at us
put them in the tub
when you make a pasta from scratch it
feels a little bit softer yeah
it's definitely like a rougher texture
fresh pasta actually cooks really fast
so we don't need to boil this for too
long all right let's give it a little
oh okay
you shouldn't do that okay
is it good
a little dente never forget to save your
pasta water it looks good let's keep it
going cruising one tablespoon of olive
oil
pancetta crisp it up look at the color
on that nice i love
bacon grease and pancetta grease one of
my second favorite foods minced shallot
stir what's your favorite pasta shape i
really do enjoy rigatoni anything kind
of weird like the trumpets i am obsessed
with i think originates my favorite i
love it yeah it looks like a little hot
the garlic is going in
calabrian chili look at that color
tomato paste it's all starting to really
come together in the pan it smells
amazing you know you want to toast up
that tomato paste
and time for
vodka so we're doing
half cup
half cup two shots of vodka
and we want to evaporate okay no we
don't want you're in a full vodka flavor
yeah this is college totino's pizza
rolls and vodka all right
that looks
we're doing one cup of pasta water the
reason you want to save your pasta water
is the starches in it will help thicken
up your sauce and in case you have
forgotten it is now time for our pizza
roll filling pizzagates
pizza pizzagate it has cheese so
it'll be good yeah melt that into your
delicious bowl of vodka
i wonder if those little balls of cheese
like are gonna melt or if they're like
so processed that they stay that way
guess what the pizza roll mascot tony
wait so we gonna get some names yeah
what does it look like it's a pizza roll
with two eyes
his name does it sounds like a human
name yes georgino
georgino
pete and his middle name is
kanye
[Music]
[Music]
right so it seems like the cheese is not
melting so let's blend it yeah good idea
yeah just a fair warning in my splash so
do you want me to do it okay all right
i'm gonna add a little bit of pasta
water
so it's easy to brown it good job brie
thank you keep it up
keep giving me a good energy blend nice
and smooth we're adding in our heavy
whipping cream whipping cream aged
silence whoever
came up with this tomato
and heavy cream combination the genius
they should be
knighted parmesan cheese parmesan cheese
make it rain
and now
for our
little rigged tortinos
there i am
oh come on alex
saucy's warm
we need some friends in the pool
this pool is very crowded and now
truffle butter
that's fancy yeah really good and fancy
here pasta looks great but we have a few
more things to do so let's get
that
[Music]
[Music]
oh that was a workout riya i commend you
for your job
thank you and what we have we have the
rigatotino olive vodka and we sprinkled
pizza roll breadcrumbs
crispy pancetta fresh basil grata black
pepper fresh basil i already said that
and black truffle and we are done
[Music]
very fancy
[Music]
all right we have a special guest to try
our creations
[Music]
do you guys know each other yeah i met
her once
do you like my necklace yeah what is it
it's pearl i'm fancy yes
do you want to wear them oh my gosh no
thank you
have a bite and um guess what we made a
fancy today
that's good that's very yummy actually
there's truffle on it so it does look
very fancy what are the flavor elements
in the like sauce
pizza so tomato you have cheese can you
guess anything pizza component but less
fancy than this
like a bagel bite or something
walmart a pizza roll yes
and it also has about five cups of vodka
oh did we make a pizza of our fancy this
is the fanciest pizza roll i've ever had
[Applause]
now we have one last things to do don't
make mistakes three two one make it
fancy
[Music]
you